As a professional content creator
that gets featured in major publications all the time,
CNN people, Hollywood Reporter,
Tamarind Hall show. I create content for money.
I make money on the content I make.
And I truly fucking love this vlogging kit from TikTok Shop.
It comes with everything you need.
I haven't had a light this whole time.
I just had to use a window.
This thing's amazing.
I'm pretty sure it's exactly like the other viral light.
It just also comes with a tripod,
the microphone. The most you have to do is get this little attachment.
If you have an iPhone, if you don't have a phone that has like,
a Jack, I'm not kidding you.
This tripod also, it folds down so little,
so it's really easy to take wherever you have to go.
All the attachments come right off.
You just break this bad boy down.
And even comes with, like,
a little bag to carry it with you.
I'm telling you,
if you have somebody in your life that wants to start creating content,
if you yourself wanna start creating content,
this little tripod is absolutely worth the money
and absolutely gonna help you create better content.
It's linked right here if you want one. I highly recommend it.